good morning Baltimore
Thank You Bishop Thomas for bringing us
under this beautiful auspices to pay
tribute to our darling precious Elijah
mr. president and mr. president and mr.
vice president
Madam Secretary Archbishop Lawrence
bishop members of the clergy
distinguished guests too early of your
for our darling Elijah as Speaker of the
House I had the sad honor and personal
privilege to bring the condolences of
the entire Congress of the United States
to Maya the Cummings family the people
the constituents of Elijah's district
people of Baltimore to our entire
country I say that with great authority
because yesterday my friends and those
of you who loved Elijah yesterday Maya
gave us the privilege of having a
celebration of Elijah's life in the
capital of the United States the first
african-american law maker ever to serve
in repose lie in repose
[Music]
it was so beautiful
and as has been referenced Elijah
brought people together in life of
different parties and in his death of
different parties and that's why I'm so
pleased that yesterday service was very
bipartisan in fact it took bipartisan
agreement for Elijah to lie in repose on
the same catapult that Abraham Lincoln
lay in repose
[Music]
and so today we have a very strong
bipartisan of Elijah's colleagues from
the House of Representatives led by arch
chair of the black caucus Karen bass our
leader Steny Hoyer John Lewis Marsha who
got the nod and I'm happy to get it as
well and so many of our members of the
house in a bipartisan fashion please
rise to be recognized and their families
and their staff Elijah staff John Lewis
where are you John Lewis and we had a
strong representation from the United
States Senate in a bipartisan way
yesterday today also led by Ben Cardin
and Chris Van Hollen bring so many
senators here today
bishop thomas how brilliant was it of
Elijah's parents to name him Elijah as
the senate as the secretary said the
more Lord the God is my Lord and as we
know from the Old Testament there is a
tradition to leave a seat at the table
for Elijah who might show up
but our Elijah always made a seat at the
table for others who made a seat at the
table for children who needed an
education for even new members of
Congress so that he could mentor them
for all who wanted to be part of the
American dream Elijah himself personally
lived the American dream and he wanted
everyone else to have that opportunity
hence many seats at the table how
fortunate for her country that his
parents also taught him to live up to
his name how blessed are we all to know
him and to benefit from his friendship
and his leadership Elijah was a proud
man proud of his heritage proud of
Baltimore
and proud of America he always appealed
to our better angels and to the promise
of America calling us to live up to our
principles and for a higher purpose as
he said does this is so all the words
that we will use that are the best words
or words that Elijah used was he was
when we were not meeting the needs of
children in our country he said we are
better than this
he felt himself to a high standard and
that is why I've called him the North
Star of Congress our guiding light Thank
You Maya for giving me this opportunity
to speak at the Baltimore celebration as
well as yesterday
of Elijah's life previously I've seen
some of you over time speaking as
Speaker of the House before at st. James
Episcopal Church to speak of the funeral
service for congressman parren Mitchell
a sad and proud day for the Baltimore
community in our country that day paying
tribute to Peron was both an official
and a personal honor my D'Alessandro
family and the mitchell family have been
friends for generations now it is my
great honor and personal sadness to join
you at the new psalmist Baptist Church
Elijah's church to celebrate Elijah's
life as I said yesterday members of
Congress said goodbye to Elijah Maya
gave us the honor again upholding that
official service in the statuary hall of
the house at that time I said this was
appropriate because Elijah was master of
the house master of the house in his
chairmanship of the
Committee on Oversight and reform he
lived up to his responsibilities to hold
the federal government accountable to
the laws of the land one word I would
use to describe Elijah over and over
again this is the word future he was
there to make the future for our
children whom he called as has been said
our living messengers to a future we
will never see but he wanted for those
children to have a future worthy of
their aspirations and he wanted them to
have a future built on our values
continue to be built on our family and
as a master of the house he was also the
mentor of the house so anybody in here
be mentored by Elijah Cummings he was no
surprise that when we had this election
and we won the Congress that Elijah said
send me as many freshmen as you can
because I want to help them be oriented
to reach the full their fullest
potential in the House of
Representatives so wonderful that he did
that in all members whether new or not
benefited from the generosity of his
spirit sometimes the candor of how we do
our work whether we asked her not the
candor was there and again it was an
honor to share again this some of these
thoughts about our dear Elijah Elijah
loved Baltimore and his district he was
my Baltimore brother in Congress we had
our chats about Baltimore all the time
he's loved and respected his
constituents by example he gave people
hope by his parish he fought for what is
right by his brilliance knowledge and
legal prowess he made a difference in so
many ways fighting for gun violence
prevention
expanding opportunity for everyone
recognizing now this was the most recent
recognizing the cost of prescription
drugs hurt
the health and economic well-being of
America's working families he was
willing to reach across the aisle even
across the Capitol even down
Pennsylvania Avenue so it should be a
source of pride to all of us who loved
Elijah that the Committee Chairman
immediately named HR 3 the lower drug
cost Act now
the Elijah II Cummings lower cost
Dalton are both from a connection gave
me special entree into the thinking
largest thinking which helped me a
speaker our love of the Orioles and the
Ravens made it fun Thank You Baltimore
for your contribution to the greatness
of the United States of America when I
spoke on Wednesday my brother Tommy
dalesandro service I acknowledged that
we would be honoring Elijah today we
lost two great leaders in one week we
did involve tomorrow
one thing that Elijah one of the things
that Elijah my brother Tommy and I think
from Baltimore and I representing San
Francisco had in common was the pride we
took in Baltimore our Baltimore another
thing Tommy Elijah and I had and I in
representing San Francisco had in common
that our hearts are full of love for
America there's two tell them in San
Francisco for us love means letting
other versions exist and that's exactly
what Elijah did respecting respecting
the views of others reaching across the
aisle building community and content
consensus Thank You Maya thank you to
children and to your entire family for
sharing Elijah with us and for loving
him so much he you were the source of
his strength and inspiration I hope it
is a comfort to you that so many people
mourn your sad loss and are praying for
you at this sad time as we always pray
for God to bless america let us
acknowledge that God truly blessed
America with the life and legacy of
Elijah II Tommy's mentor master of the
house
Northstar mr. chairman
master of the house may he rest in peace
Elijah Cummings thank you
[Music]
[Applause]